what is the shared DNA between Elite
athletes and these Elite creatives they
love their craft every single minute of
it they're obsessed with being the best
that they can be and that's where their
Joy comes not in the end result the
discipline that I learned from sport
really helped the creativity because as
ethereal is being creative and when is
that good idea gonna come if you still
give yourself some sense of structure
then you're working towards something in
sport if you really want to get to the
top you have to be creative you have to
think outside the box about how you're
going to push your mind and your body to
truly achieve greatness